si aucune date n'a encore été annoncée
la liste des noms des prochains
ministres ne va pas tarder à se faire
connaître alors quels sont les élus
yvelinois pressenti au gouvernement un
fait le point le maire de poissy arrive
en pôle position karl olive a déjà
accueilli plusieurs fois le président de
la république dans sa ville ils ont même
joué au foot ensemble lors du match
célébrant les 50 ans du variétés club de
france en octobre dernier c'est aussi à
poissy qu emmanuel macron a décidé de
lancer officiellement sa campagne
présidentielle en mars le pisciacais
donc dans les faveurs du président de la
république après avoir rendu un rapport
en février sur l'insertion des jeunes
par le sport dans les quartiers car le
livre pourrait être pressenti au
ministère de la ville et non pas à celui
des sports en raison d'un conflit
d'intérêt sa soeur brigitte henriques
étant la présidente du comité national
olympique et sportif français
autre mère yvelinois présumés au
gouvernement arnaud péricard ce dernier
a lancé en octobre un comité de soutien
à saint germes en lait pour porter la
candidature d'emmanuel macron étant sous
la bannière horizons ce serait le moyen
de faire entrer au gouvernement un
soutien de l'ancien premier ministre
edouard philippe il est également
l'avocat de nombreux sportifs il a
notamment défendu radio ancien joueur du
psg et tony yoka boxeur yvelinois arnaud
péricard serait donc pressenti en tant
que ministre des sports il y aussi
l'ancien ministre de la ville nadia et
membre de la commission des finances
elle pourrait repartir pour un nouveau
ministère en 2020 elle avait participé à
un rapport concernant l'impôt sur la
fortune immobilière
nadia et pourrait donc se voir attribuer
un nouveau ministère comme celui de
l'économie et des finances les députés
yvelinois jean-noël barrot et aurore
bergé ont également leur chance déjà
pressenti à l'économie en 2017 est
actuellement vice président de la
commission des finances jean noël barrot
pourrait peut-être se faire une place
tout comme aurore bergé la députée a
rendu en 2020 un rapport sur le
développement de la culture pour tous
elle pourrait donc être présente au
ministère de la culture cependant parmi
toutes ces personnalités une seule
serait vraisemblablement choisi
elisabeth bornes emmanuel macron doivent
se résoudre à trouver un équilibre
géographique afin de ne pas présenter un
gouvernement trop parisien la seule
titude le futur gouvernement sera
resserré autour d'une quinzaine de
ministres et sera en place avant
vendredi 20 mai